a new poll out from USA Today and
Suffolk University shows Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis ahead of President
Trump for the 2024 GOP nomination and he
is not just up a little bit the poll
shows him up 23 points on the former
president in a hypothetical matchup
that's
56-23 now I am as skeptical of polls as
anybody I think that most of them are
made up and statistics are totally fake
but there are enough indicators at this
point to show that Rhonda Santos poses a
serious threat to Donald Trump's
perceived hegemony over the GOP Trump
obviously thinks so that's why he's been
attacking DeSantis and he started up
real attacks just before in the midterms
and DeSantis has managed to achieve this
status in a few different ways one he's
in office while Trump is out of office
so he can do things president Trump
can't really do things right now because
he's a Mar-A-Lago two
DeSantis is on social media Trump is not
on social media all he's on is the truth
platform that people don't really go to
other than to find his statements but
there is a third distinction that not
that many people are talking about but
that DeSantis is clearly hoping to ride
all the way to taking Trump's place
president Trump is the candidate of the
covid vaccine and Ron DeSantis wants to
make sure that you know that he is not
this is the key that a lot of people
don't talk about with DeSantis and I'm
not saying I am not saying that Trump
deserves all of the criticism about
kovid and that Ron DeSantis is
absolutely 100 percent clean on the
covid issue that's not exactly what I'm
saying
what I am saying is in the public
perception
with good reason I think
Trump is seen as the guy who gave fauci
a platform who promoted the vaccine that
seems to have some problems with it
again I don't know that any other
politician in Trump's place would have
done anything any differently or would
have performed any better I'm not I'm
just saying that's what happened
when Trump was in office
and Ron DeSantis although he was a
little bit cautious about covet at first
he reopened Florida really really
quickly and he has been ever more so
anti-covered anti-public Health
establishment even anti-vaccine
so DeSantis who made the vaccines
available to people who wanted it in
Florida
but did not want to mandate the vaccine
he is now impaneling a grand jury
to look into the abuses from the vaccine
manufacturers
Florida you know it is against the law
to mislead and to misrepresent
particularly when you're talking about
the efficacy of a drug we see just the
other uh just recently Florida got 3.2
billion through legal action against
those responsible for the opioid crisis
and so it's not like this is something
that's unprecedented so today I'm
announcing a petition with the Supreme
Court of Florida to impanel a Statewide
grand jury to investigate any and all
wrongdoing in Florida with respect to
covid-19 vaccines and we anticipate that
we will get the approval for that that
will be something that will be impaneled
most likely in the Tampa Bay area and
that will come with legal processes that
will be able to get more information and
to bring legal accountability for those
who committed misconduct
Ron DeSantis is a smart smart guy I
think this is the right thing to do so I
applaud him for doing it but it's also
politically probably the single smartest
thing that Ron DeSantis can do because
Donald Trump's biggest weakness in a GOP
Primary is not actually his mouth or he
says mean things no people actually kind
of get a kick out of that it's not his
Twitter he's not on Twitter well he's on
Twitter he's just not using it now even
after Elon Musk took over
it's covid that's the weakness that's
the way that Ron DeSantis can position
himself to the right of Donald Trump
that's the way that Ron DeSantis can
counter the claims that he's a Squish
and a moderate the never Trump candidate
and and all of the criticisms that are
going to come along with him by virtue
of his place in the race and as the
candidate who isn't Donald Trump and uh
by virtue of the people that DeSantis is
attracting the never trumpers the the
Liberals and the squishes and he's
attracting those people and through no
fault of his own because he's not Donald
Trump and so he's got to figure out a
way to tell the conservatives and the
base no I'm I'm with you I'm a
conservative guy the covid vaccine issue
the fact that we were lied to about
safety of the vaccine we were lied to
about the efficacy of the vaccine we
were forced in most of the country to
take the vaccine if he can really go
after the people who peddled the vaccine
that's going to go a long way for
DeSantis the rest of the show continues
now miss Mr Davies tells me we have a
magnificent movie trailer that I have to
see I have to focus all my powers
of cultural perception on this to tell
you what this is about you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]